so Kelly one thing that I see on a lot
of browsers they might have like a
private mode or an incognito mode what
do those things generally do and how
private or Incognito are there and what
should we still think about even if we
are using those modes
so generally a private motor incognito
means that what is happening in that
browsing session on your computer stays
there so you know sometimes when you
browse the web you get things like
cookies that remember who you are
remember different things that have
happened so you know for instance a site
that you visited it before maybe that
you've logged in before so what those
windows do is they say that once you
close that window everything is
forgotten on your computer
but what they don't mean is that no one
can know what happened because they
don't protect against other software
running your computer if you're at work
your work administrator might still have
access to what's happening on your
computer or even the Wi-Fi network
um might have some sort of record of
what traffic's going through it so it'll
clean out a lot of the things that might
be saved on your computer when you're
normally browsing and what are the
disadvantages of using that mode
um the disadvantages are you know some
of the things that cookies do are
conveniences for you so so for instance
if you remember your login on a website
that makes it much easier for you to log
in next time or maybe you know you want
to have a your video service remember
what videos you like so that it can give
you better suggestions next time so you
know the internet there are a lot of
advantages to some of the things like
cookies it's just a question of you know
in that particular moment does is that
something that's useful to you or is
that something that you want to avoid by
using a private or incognito browsing
super useful thanks so much Kelly